does anybody want to smell some smelling
salt yes i forgot to last time i got to
wake up
we'll go with norman because he's cocky
ready now what is this powder you gotta
open it no it's like a crystal open it
up but don't throw it at me or anything
when you i won't throw it when the smell
hits you
[ __ ] freight train watch this
no way no no way wait you don't take it
like a
just take a sniff go ahead ready here we
go
nose bleeding have you ever done this
before oh yeah i did it with theo holy
dick me and theo did it the first time
bigger nose
bigger nose i bet ari's like a
bloodhound i bet he smells us different
i'm tearing up
like who the [ __ ] how can you do that
where's the top
i don't know down there bring that over
here
give it to daddy i'm snotting i'm
snotting oh my god i didn't hate sting
so bad i've only done this a couple of
times before but i remember what it's
like let's see if i've i've like
minimized it in my mind i went too close
to the bottle i think
you got to take a big hit get it in
there
you look like you watched my special
on netflix
i i was ready for it this time nobody
but i still don't mind taking another
hit dude i like that it wakes you up
i feel cleared out oh [ __ ] i had covered
before that oh my god killed it it's so
surprising right yeah right i didn't
think it was like that
my ears popped
whoa
and you have to keep it in this plastic
bag um shout out to how do you say his
name jamie the devil